Today, Commander Whitson, you have broken the record...
...for the most total time spent in space by an American astronaut:...
534 days and counting.
That's an incredible record to break,...
...and on behalf of our nation and frankly, on behalf of the world,...
...I'd like to congratulate you. That is really something.
And I'd like to know, how does it feel to have broken such a big and important record?
Well, it's actually a huge honor to break a record like this,...
...but it's an honor for me basically to be representing all the folks at NASA...
...who make the space flight possible and who make me setting this record feasible.
And so, it's a very exciting time to be at NASA.
We are all very much looking forward as directed by your new NASA bill.
We're excited about the missions to Mars in the 2030s.